for joining us here at noon i'm heather
mills we are following breaking news at
this hour you no longer are required to
wear a mask in nevada but don't throw
them away yet governor steve sisolak
made the announcement just a few hours
ago
let me be clear the state will no longer
require masks in public places but
employers in school and organizations
including school districts may set their
own policies and i encourage them to
work with their employees and
communities to ensure that policies are
in place
and we have heard from ccsd masks will
stay on in schools through today so
families can talk to their kids this
afternoon about the choice ccsd quickly
said masks will no longer be required
anywhere but on buses the teachers union
supporting lifting the mandate governor
sisalak asked though that you still
respect the wishes of those who do wear
masks or businesses that want you to
keep a mask when you're in their
business
i want kindness to be just as contagious
as kovit is
kovit 19 has brought out the best and
the worst in society
and i'm always proud to be in nevada and
to see the way nevada's take care of one
another
here's where you do have to wear those
masks still hospitals long-term care
clinics and other health facilities the
state will work out details of that in
the coming hours days but they are also
still required by the federal government
on airports planes buses including
school buses
joining us with some reaction to the
mass mandate being lifted joe moller
who's at bagel cafe on buffalo near
summerlin and joe you were actually you
were there when the governor made this
announcement so what was the reaction
there
heather it was definitely interesting
being here when this all happened at
first there were some confusions do i
have to put the mask on can i take it
off at what point can i take it off well
some people here are already starting to
take it off they just took them out of
the the sign down here at the
host stand that told you you're required
to wear it but they took that down but
as you can imagine there was confusion
at first when this all went down now
take a look it's pretty busy here some
are still wearing them but some are not
the manager and some employees were
happy to learn about this change now we
were here as people got the news many
did not know about the change right when
it happened but as the morning went on
you could see more and more people not
wearing them i caught up with the
customer and the owner who are glad they
are no longer required
i guess you said it's a breath of fresh
air
it was kind of weird not being able to
see the interaction with people
sometimes the smile does a lot for
people it's exciting
i mean because it's been so long and i
understand the mass mandate i always
understood
it's just we're tired as a business
fighting with the people
[Music]
another live look here in bagel cafe so
you see some employees have their mass
off that was a one woman there who was
pretty excited not to not have to wear
it we talked to one woman who says she
will choose to still wear it in public
but she's happy that it's now up to
whoever
opinions if you want to wear it you
still can reporting live joe muller live
local now